dai che tanto che lo aspettavate questo
cazzo di momento prima o poi vero
cazzo mi odio a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a sto cazzo proprio siamo su
tre fa vj3 ri siamo tornati su stacca
gatta entrato sei molto più figo di
prima zio credimi secondo dati su five
lights freddy's dopo un po di tempo che
non ci giocavo grazie a dio
niente è uscito hanno fatto anche il 3
lista cagata devo assolutamente giocarlo
perché mi sono arrivati messaggi anche
durante la notte che mi chiedevano fari
gioca fa in 3d grazie veramente vedo se
riesco a sopravviverne una di notte
anche se la vedo difficile con la
chiamata me ne sbatto i [ __ ]
perché sono trasgredirà gas in europa
cos'è che già è già qua ci siamo già mi
devo prendere male è diverso dal secondo
cioè l'ambientazione completamente che
belliche quebec e teneri dobbiamo
resistere fino alle 6 del mattino cosa
molto semplice a me dire è diverso
sarebbe come serve per riavviare il
sistema ok non sapeva bene un importo
ragazzino scoprirò dopo a cosa serve
giorno è normale questo tizio qui si e
non sarebbe questo che ci sono inter
farcelo slann darman il cazzo è successo
sarebbe tipo questo qui il tipo che sta
qua credono quindi io sono papà perfetto
layout ciao perché si riavviano state le
che bello ma di vendere un attimo in
giro che cosa c'è perché non ho ancora
capito un cazzo cioè uscita quale
malattia mentale mi costringe a rimanere
qui quando l'uscita e qui quale è
un'altra uscita c'è son due fantastico
20 non vengono dove sono i nemici sono
le 4 di notte tra tosto per vince la
cazzo non è successo niente meglio un
cossyra che avevano un dono di alla sa
cosa però meglio ragazzo
che ne curò bene non è successo
bene il primo giorno meno male sono
riuscito a sopravvivere va bene che è
successo cioè matrix ragazzi c'è
morpheus che cazzo è cosa posso muovermi
io sono freddi io sono cos'è una
ciabatta questa non c'è batta che si
muove manco pack mancia l'asta grafica
in hd full 4k fallo minuti con la mamma
ha detto di non seguire gli sconosciuti
per io ti seguo perché c'è un bel
culetto andassi è andato di qua perfetta
una delle cazzo fai sono partito di
quello dove sono uscito prima doveva i
due vice
dove vai dove devo andare errore non
posso andare allora sei stronzo nei
cervelli mi hanno stuprato seconda notte
si ragazzi non ho capito cosa è successo
né quando ho giocato la prima volta
ventilation error aiuto spediti spegni
ti non so come si spenge è un errore
nella ventilazione bene bene
c'è qualcuno che si è ficcato nei
condotti per caso no è successo perché è
andato perché è tornato tutto buio
all'improvviso ragazzi riavvia la
ventilazione riavvia la ventilazione a
cazzo è successo qualcosa nella mente
non so ma parcheggio di black out io sto
gioco non lo sto capendo abbiate
pazienza ce la fai a che beh ce l'ho
fatta già fatta nel mentre che
dana [ __ ] tua sorella ma quella brutta
di tos nei due di sorelle una brutta una
bella quella brutta sono ancora vivo
sono anche il mouse è finito giù però
sono vivo seriamente che cazzo è
successo ventilation no no no fermi non
ho capito e ha posto un tizio a caso a
caso proprio dalla fermi un attimo che
non ho capito c'è un tizio c'era un
tizio era qui come ha fatto a saltarmi
addosso da sera qui visto qualcosa
muoversi non mi è piaciuto ma non ho
ancora capito perché
amico mio dove sei finito via via via
via via via togli con si toglie ragazzi
e anzi camera system non ho riavvia
tutto riavviato io non ho capito cosa
sta succedendo c'è gente che si sta
muovendo nel ma non capisco chi cazzo
sono è quello il problema dove chi era
quel tipo di prima che cosa devo guarda
tesoro sei veramente un figo
se ti azzardi a muoverti da dove il
cazzo sei e vabbè è qualcos'altro e
dimmi che mi è anche finita la nutella
nel frigo dimmi perché so se sono finiti
anche i ghiaccioli e non si sa mai
[Musica]
ecco la goduria la donna l'orgasmo
ma basta a freddy è stato stuprato
violentemente adesso adesso il toro non
di nomi come si chiamano bunny nicolò
nell'ascolto zio io ti seguo falomi
io non ho capito ma ciao bello no no
ascolta no perché mi deve stuprare i
pupazzi che c'è la pupazzo filia è una
nuova forma di erotismo con i ragazzi
sono due notti che sopravvive in file
mente 13 due sono arrivati alla seconda
notte
poi ho perso sempre quindi sono arrivato
allo stesso punto di colori prima in una
sola giocata è impossibile show nervo mi
chiamo sono neanche parti l'importante
che non si muova nessuno nei condotti
nei fuori e condotti non previsto un
casting ed era meglio non dirlo prova
balcani ragazzi non avevo più di chi li
ascolta freddi da allora fai una cosa
dubbi controlli che non entra nessuno e
io ti do dei biscotti merda c'era
qualcuno li fuoco ma ho fatto e se no
vabbè io riavvio tutto perché faccio
prima no non è il blackout no kat
almeno quello ma chiedo il tipo di prima
[Musica]
cosa sapevo c'è la mamma [ __ ] però
lo sapevo che ha ormai non ci ho già
imparato in una giocata ma se ti
offrissi della pizza e lo vuoi la pizza
non la vuoi e allora niente pizza
porca [ __ ] che a cagà non avete idea
della ca ga che mette questo cazzo di
file nights freddy's diversissimo dagli
altri la cosa veramente bella e che non
bastava tipo tenere no vabbè che carispe
è già sparito non anche non è neanche
passata un'ora che devo capire ma lei
audio con saltasse
cosa calmissimo salve ma è per caso lei
michael jackson che lo vedo con
microfono michael jackson non è michael
j
però ci somiglia più o meno simile vivo
arriva grazie dov'è il mouse quando ho
trovato che sia saltato il mouse
pazienza lei audio play audi a caso a
caso qualcosa funzioneranno tanto
benedetto perché maledizione ma per cosa
devo fare
via no no video video euro
[ __ ] siamo alla terza ora almeno
almeno alla quinta da poter sperare di
riuscire a vincere almeno quello che poi
senti allora io non ho capito ecco
questo tar [ __ ] basta corrotto ingoiati
son rotto sono travasato il bene è stato
bello che sono arrivati alla terza notte
che per una partita c'è con una
registrazione sola non è male credo che
i ragazzi
se avete di consiglio da darmi
batteriche così nel prossimo episodio
meno di fare meglio io vado a uccidermi
adesso anzi questo in piazza delle
telecamere in casa e faccio la stessa
cosa per i ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto cosa sente lascia il tuo
commento mi piace se avete dei consigli
datemi lì perché via gesuiti di
scrittura ci vediamo al prossimo bella
ragazza